So, here is our normal distribution again.
I'm going to write it as "exp" for exponential         .
The truth is when you're new to this this looks really cryptic.
When you're with statistics for many years as I have been,
you wake up in the middle of the night and you can recite this formula.
It's as normal as getting breakfast in the morning or having a beer after dinner.
What I want to get into your brains is not the complexity of the formula.
I want you to really understand how this formula is constructed.
I you to understand the quadratic penalty term of deviations from the expectation
of the mean of this expression.
Then the exponential that squeezes it back into the curves.
That's basically what it is.
We can draw values from this normal distribution just the same way as we flipped coins before.
The way to look at this is any value x has this probability up here.
This is nothing else but a notation of the probability of x for a normal distribution with µ and σ².
So, a value x that has twice the high bar than some other value x'
will have twice as much of a probability of being drawn.
Now, obviously, the normal has an entire continuous space of outcomes.
And obviously that renders each individual outcome of probability 0.
But, in essence, you can think of the height of this thing over here
as being proportional to the probability that this value is being drawn.